this video is sponsored by viz media
there are a few things more saturated in
this world
than the zombie genre anime may have its
isakai but movies tv series comics and
yes
even anime and manga have made it rather
tricky to find any new kind of take on
the genre
another guy wakes up and there are more
people eating people and sometimes
they're dead
or alive or infected or can walk or can
run and they meet a group of survivors
and one of them gets bit in secret and
then tells nobody and that society
starts to fall apart
and in the process of surviving we
suddenly realized that the real monsters
were the humans all along
so when viz approached me and asked me
hey do you want to talk about one of our
newest releases
a zombie manga i was like uh
i'll get back to you in that one i was
very skeptical about it but after giving
it a try i was pleasantly surprised to
see a genuinely fresh take on the
setting
so i present to you zom 100 bucket list
of the dead everyone who's had an office
job knows this feeling
i do i had an office job because i work
for the bbc did you know that
i didn't know if you know that you're
sat at your desk doing work you don't
care about for a company that doesn't
care about
you like when i work for the bbc it
feels like nothing you do or achieve
really means anything you slave away for
an unhealthy number of hours minimal
breaks unpaid overtime and the worst
part is
you take it all home with you when
you're at home all you can think about
is the dread of going back to work so
you barely take care of yourself
days after days of instant ramen and an
unhealthy amount of money spent on
ubereats a short night of light sleep
then you're back at the office as
quickly as you left don't you ever just
wish it could all
just go away don't you wish there was a
nice little fun event
like i don't know a zombie apocalypse
rendering humanity in a state of peril
where deaths around you at every turn
and everyone you care about is either in
danger or dead just so you can get away
from that life
welcome to zom 100 bucket list of the
dead a story about
exactly that akira tender has worked at
a company that's just exploited him for
three
long years and after he's completely
reached his breaking point from
ungrateful co-workers constant unpaid
overtime and soul-breaking levels of
stress he wakes up to find the world in
sheer anarchy from a zombie apocalypse
and after seeing all the blood
gore and chaos surrounding him he thinks
to himself just one
thing oh [ __ ] i'm gonna be late for work
but after the sheer gravity of the
situation he's in finally sinks in he
reacts how anyone else would do erupting
in pure jubilation because hey
anything's better than working at an
office shop am i right
bbc immediately he feels a weight off
his shoulders and the world around him
suddenly feels full of color and joy
again
so all these dreams he had in the back
of his mind things he'd put off
indefinitely because his job prevented
it he sets out to do and achieve so he
starts to fill out his to-do list and
try not to let a bunch of murderous
brain-eating drones get in the way of
his newfound happiness
this is akira tendo's bucket list of the
dead which uh
is a slightly strangely worded title i
know as it's his bucket list and not the
dead and you know
seems a bit difficult for the dead to
have a bucket list of things to do
before they die when they're already
die now it takes a lot in the current
age to make a zombie apocalypse story
interesting it's a formula that's been
overplayed and stretched out even
further than the walking dead felt like
past season 4.
there are a few examples of fun zombie
stories in anime and manga and there are
also a fair few examples in cinema of
zombie films with a light-hearted tone
falling outside the traditional genre of
horror this
unlike a lot of those stories takes the
concept and runs with it knowing full
well everyone watching it understands
zombies and has seen it plenty of times
before i mean the manga hard opens up in
a scene of akira watching a zombie movie
and loudly exclaiming
god i wish that was me in his best
pornhub comments voice and because of
this there's none of that pissing about
trying to figure out what these things
are what to name them and how to deal
with them they're zombies we know it the
writer knows it and so does everyone
else in the manga so the only repetitive
tropes and zombie film cliches you see
are played up for being those exact
things it somehow does succeed in being
a zombie apocalypse story that feels
fresh and interesting
confessing to his co-worker and in the
process finding his boss who's now a
zombie and resigning by rugby tackling
him through the door
this is the kind of [ __ ] you imagine in
the shower with all the shampoo bottles
applauding you as horrific as a zombie
apocalypse may be
the juxtaposition between this and a
carefree guy just living his life to the
fullest while everyone else is stuck in
a cliche zombie movie is what makes this
manga everyone else is out there
scavenging life essential resources
food medicine weapon no toilet paper
though that was pretty unrealistic akira
though
doesn't have these problems he runs out
of something far more precious
that's right beer thus ensues
beer shopping of the dead he reconnects
with old friends goes on road trip
adventures
anything you can think of he's on it
like a car bonnet it was honestly
refreshing to see
this positive outlook in such a horrific
situation we've seen
zombie stories with a more lighthearted
tone before but what immediately
connected with me was how it was used to
let akira really reflect on everything
he wanted to be
everything he wanted to do everything
he'd forgotten about himself
only took the end of human civilization
itself to get to that realization
better late than never right zom 100
really brings to light this desire for
anyone who feels like they're in a bit
of a rut in their lives
whether it be a dead end job no job at
all or start pursuing something in life
that doesn't bring them
any joy when you're a kid you look at
these adults who'd follow the rules and
have to go to work all the time and that
just seemed
boring we were never gonna be like that
we had dreams we had ambitions and
nothing could stop us from doing what we
wanted to do
but as we grew older we got shackled by
the weight of responsibility
and slowly but surely we became trapped
sometimes you fantasize about something
that can give you an escape from all
these responsibilities
maybe something fantastical could happen
like getting transported to another
world
finding out you've won the lottery or
even
the end of the world itself what we have
here
is a wholesome uplifting tale set in the
middle of a zombie apocalypse it's not
just about zombies
it's a reminder how easy it was to
forget all the things we said we were
going to do
all the things we said we wanted to be
and sometimes
all you need is that kickstart in life
to get that fire going again
even if that thing was the literal
apocalypse and if that sounds like
something for you
then i highly recommend giving zom 100
bucket list of the dead a chance
and yeah that's pretty much it
again thank you to this media for
sponsoring me today you know this is the
very first time i've accepted the
sponsorship where i talk about
one singular title or manga or anime or
whatever and the reason for that is
because
i genuinely enjoyed it i didn't know if
i was going to make a video when they
first approached me but honestly i'm
kind of glad they did because i would
have never
read this manga if they didn't and they
were kind enough to give me the physical
volumes look at that
yeah guys real books still exist look at
that honestly i miss the feeling of
reading physical manga so much i've
really enjoyed this experience
so if you want to give zom 100 bucket
list of the dead a try then volumes 1
and 2 are available right now all you
have to do is click the link in the
description
and yeah i hope this video wasn't too
short for you this is kind of new for me
as well i wanted to make something
short and quick but i guess that means
you guys didn't have to wait as long for
new content
so i'll probably leave it at that i'll
keep it short and sweet
i've been gig up and i'll see you all
next time